ça y est c'est l'hiver il fait froid
normale et dans les bulletins météo on
va donc à nouveau voir fleurir les
fameuses température ressentie alors ce
qui est bien c'est que c'est toujours
super alarmiste ça donne un petit côté
et film catastrophe au bulletin météo
mais est ce que c'est bien scientifique
comme concept ça la température
ressentie est bien plus ou moins on va
voir que l'idée de départ peut paraître
pertinente mais qu en pratique ça ne
marche pas du tout
[Musique]
la raison principale qui fait que c'est
compliqué de parler de température
ressentie c'est que le fait qu'on échoue
ou froid n'est pas une question de
température
ça vous paraît bizarre comme affirmation
eh bien faisons une petite expérience de
pensée
imaginez que vous soyez chez vous et
qu'à l'intérieur il fasse 25 degrés
alors à 25 degrés on est bien on peut
être à poil et même sens agité ou faire
d'effort physique particulier on n'a pas
froid
on peut rester toute la journée comme ça
maintenant imaginez que vous preniez un
bain dont l'eau est à 25 degrés faites
l'essai 1
c'est jouable vous n'aurez pas trop mal
à y rentrer mais assez rapidement vous
allez avoir froid je doute que vous irez
astier et plus d'une heure surtout si
vous ne faites pas d'effort physique
particulier comme on ferait la piscine
c'est bizarre non 25 degrés dans les
deux cas dans l'air on est bien toute la
journée et dans l'eau on finit vite par
caillé et bien cette petite expérience
illustre un truc important pour le
ressenti la température on s'en fout ce
qui compte c'est le flux le flux c'est
la quantité de chaleur qui quitte votre
corps au cours du temps et c'est ce qui
va faire que vous allez avoir froid ou
pas évidemment ce flux on va le no tf a
quand même un lien avec la température
extérieure
il est proportionnel à la différence de
température entre votre peau qui est à
environ 35 degrés et le milieu extérieur
mais pour calculer le flux
on doit diviser cette différence de
température par un coefficient qu'on
appelle la résistance thermique de
surface cette résistance exprime le fait
que les échanges de chaleur à la surface
de votre peau ne se font pas de façon
parfaite et instantanée plus la
résistance est élevé plus le flux sera
faible
le flux s'est donc l'écart de
température / la résistance et pour ceux
qui connaissent la loi d'ohm en
électricité un inégal usuraires c'est un
peu analogue
évidemment la question maintenant c'est
combien vaut cette résistance est bien
quand vous êtes chez vous à l'intérieur
et à poil et vous environ 0,15
donc pour une différence de température
de 10 degrés entre votre peau et l'air
on peut brancher sa dans le calcul et ça
fait un flux d'environ 65 watts par
mètre carré
alors oui le flux c'est par mètre carré
car ça dépend de la surface totale de
peau exposée pour un être humain adulte
on est à un peu plus d'un mètre carré et
demi donc ça va faire au total environ
100 watts 100 watts et donc la puissance
thermique qui s'échappe de votre corps
quand vous êtes à poil chez vous par 25
et ça correspond à peu près aussi à la
chaleur produite par votre organisme
du fait de votre métabolisme des
calories que vous brûlez quand vous êtes
au repos et donc dans ces conditions il
y à un équilibre entre la chaleur
produite par votre corps est celle qui
s'échappe dans l'air extérieur
vous n'avez ni froid ni chaud vous
pouvez rester aussi longtemps que vous
voulez comme ça maintenant quand vous
êtes dans un bain à 25 degrés le calcul
est similaire mais la résistance de
surface est beaucoup plus faible
la raison c'est que les échanges de
chaleur se font beaucoup mieux entre la
peau et look entre la peau et l'air les
valeurs exactes de résistance dépendrait
beaucoup de la forme de votre corps de
la baignoire du mouvement de l'eau etc
mais on peut prendre une valeur typique
de 0,01 mettez ça dans le calcul vous
voyez que ça nous fait 1000 watts par
mètre carré
cette fois ci la chaleur qui s'échappe
de votre corps est bien supérieur à ce
que produit votre métabolisme au repos
donc votre organisme va commencer à
brûler beaucoup plus de calories pour
essayer de compenser et il va vous
envoyer un signal physiologiques de ce
déséquilibre
c'est la sensation de froid au total si
on compare 25 degrés dans l'air et dans
l'eau c'est la même température est
pourtant pas du tout la même sensation
parce que ce qui compte ce n'est pas la
température c'est le flux alors petite
astuce pour les amateurs pour la même
raison vous refroidir et beaucoup plus
vite une bouteille de vin en la mettant
dans un seau avec de la glace et un peu
d'eau quand la mettant au congélateur
au delà de ça il existe un autre exemple
qui illustre très bien la prépondérance
du flux c'est le fait qu'on attribue à
certains matériaux le fait d'être chaud
ou froid quand on les touche par exemple
le carrelage c'est considéré comme froid
alors que le polystyrène on dirait que
c'est chaud et donc c'est plus agréable
de poser le pied nul sur du polystyrène
que sur du carrelage
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si on pose
un glaçon sur ces deux matériaux et bien
si le polystyrène paraît plus chaud on
peut s'attendre à ce que le glaçon ils
fondent plus vite et bien vous pouvez
faire l'expérience
voici ce que vous verrez et oui celle
inverse qui se produit le glaçon fond
plus vite sur le carrelage
la raison c'est que le polystyrène n'est
pas plus chaud que le carrelage en fait
ils sont tous les deux à la température
ambiante donc environ 20 degrés mais le
carrelage a une meilleure capacité à
échanger de la chaleur que le
polystyrène
les flux sont donc toujours plus
importants si je pose ma main à 37
degrés sur du carrelage et du
polystyrène
le carrelage absorbera plus de chaleur
d'où la sensation de froid
mais si c'est un glaçon à zéro degré
cette fois ci le carrelage donnera plus
de chaleur que le polystyrène et le
glaçon faudra plus vite
et pourtant les deux surfaces sont
toujours à la même température encore
une autre illustration du fait que ce
qui compte fondamentalement ça n'est pas
la température c'est le flux revenons
maintenant à notre météo je vous ai dit
que pour calculer le flux on divise l
écart de température par la résistance
de surface et que celle ci vaut environ
0,15 pour l'air en intérieur mais si
vous sortez dehors ça change
l'air extérieur est toujours beaucoup
plus en mouvement que l'air intérieur
qui a des petites turbulences et surtout
il peut y avoir carrément du vent en
l'absence de vent la résistance est
légèrement inférieure à celle en
intérieur environ 0,1 mais plus la
vitesse du vent est élevé plus cette
valeur va diminuer la courbe que vous
voyez ici représente la diminution de la
résistance de surface au fur et à mesure
de l'augmentation de la vitesse du vent
par exemple avec un vent à 50 km heure
la résistance n'est déjà plus que de
0,05 alors comparons deux situations
d'un côté 25 degrés et pas de vent et de
l'autre 25° aussi mais avec 50 km heure
devant et calculons le flux dans les
deux cas puisque c'est ça qui compte
donc première situation 10 degrés de
différence une résistance de 0,1
ça fait 100 watts par mètre carré de
flux dans le deuxième cas la résistance
n'est que de 0,05
ça fait 200 watts par mètre carré de
flux à température identique
on perd deux fois plus de chaleur du
fait de ce vent pour traduire ce rôle du
vent on pourrait s'amuser à donner la
météo en flux plutôt qu en température
sauf que ça n'est pas très pratique ni
très intuitif alors ce qu'on peut faire
c'est prendre notre situation à 25° 50
km heure devant et se demander quelle
température il faudrait pour que l'on
perde le même flux mais en l'absence de
vent et bien on peut faire le calcul
rapidement ses 15 degrés avec 15 degrés
et pas de vent on perdrait aussi 200
watts par mètre carré
la même chose qu'avec 25 degrés et 50 km
heure devant puisque le ressenti
physiologique est liée principalement
aux flux une manière de l'exprimer
c'est de dire qu à 25 degrés et 50 km
heure devant on ressent la même chose
qu'à 15 degrés 120
et que donc 15 degrés c'est en quelque
sorte la température ressentie
celle qui donnerait le même flux en
l'absence de vent ce petit principe de
traduire les flux en température
ressentie
il fonctionne quelle que soit la
température et la vitesse du vent à
partir des formules on peut s'amuser à
faire un petit diagramme qui exprime la
température ressentie en fonction de la
température de l'air et la vitesse du
vent dans la situation que j'ai prises
le vent conduisait à une température
ressentie dix degrés plus basses que la
température de l'air et voyez que pour
des températures plus froides ça peut
être bien pire
vous trouvez peut-être ses valeurs
exagérément basse et vous avez raison
l'explication c'est que je suis toujours
dans mon hypothèse où on est
complètement à poil
or en pratique c'est pas vraiment le cas
surtout quand la température est plus
basse et le fait de s'habiller va
complètement changer le calcul quand on
s'habille chaudement qu'est ce qu'on
fait on ne change pas la température
extérieure mais on s'isole du froid
physiquement on diminue le flux pour
prendre ça en compte dans notre calcul
c'est très simple les vêtements ajoute
une résistance thermique supplémentaire
qui suffira d'additionner on additionne
les résistances
un peu comme en électricité dans le
calcul du flux on doit prendre en compte
la somme de la résistance de surface de
tout à l'heure et de la résistance des
vêtements celle ci va dépendre
principalement de leur épaisseur et pour
une couche d'environ 1 cm on va être au
tour de 0.4 donc en l'absence de vent la
résistance sera de 0,1 plus 0.4 ça fait
0,5 au total et avec 50 km heure devant
elle sera de 0,05 plus 0,4 soit 0,45
white ça ne fait plus une grosse
différence entre les deux situations
tout à l'heure la présence du vent
divisait la résistance de surface par
deux mais avec des vêtements elle l'a
fait seulement baissé de 10% alors
prenons une situation concrète
supposons qu'on soit habillé avec des
habits ayant cette valeur de résistance
thermique et que la température de l'air
extérieur soit de 10 degrés en l'absence
de vent on peut calculer le flux avec
une résistance totale de 0,5 donc et on
trouve 50 watts par mètre carré
prenons ensuite la même situation mais
avec 50 km heure devant la résistance
totale et cette fois de seulement 0,45
et le calcul du flux donne 55 watts par
mètre carré
on peut alors chercher la température
ressentie c'est à dire celle qui donne
ce même flux de 55 watts par mètre
mais en l'absence de vent et la bonne
réponse c'est 7,5 degrés avec 5 degrés
sans vent on perd le même flux que 10
degrés avec 50 km heure devant on peut
s'amuser à mettre à jour mon petit
diagramme de tout à l'heure qui montre
la température ressentie en fonction de
la température de l'air et de la vitesse
du vent
vous voyez que quand on prend en compte
l'impact des habits la baisse de
température ressentie due au vent est
loin d'être aussi importante et ce
serait encore plus faible si on
augmentait la couche de vêtement
donc si vous êtes bien couvert la
température ressentie on s'en fout un
peu
évidemment la réalité est un peu moins
idéal que ça d'une part parce qu'on
suppose les vêtements étanche au vent ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas suivant
comment vous êtes habillé et aussi bien
sûr parce qu'il y à des parties de votre
corps qui peuvent ne pas être couvertes
notamment le visage et les mains et
c'est surtout pour ces parties là que
considéré le vent est important
notamment parce qu'il augmente
considérablement le risque de gelures
mais comme vous pouvez vous en douter
cela varie énormément d'un individu à
l'autre suivant sa peau sa pilosité la
surface exposée et c'est alors prétendre
définir une température ressentie
objective c'est un peu sans espoir
surtout qu'on l'a vu ça ne concerne que
la peau exposée pour les parties
couvertes et donc la sensation générale
de froid et bien on s'en fiche un peu
et surtout ça peut conduire à plein de
confusion par exemple si fait deux
degrés mais moins 5° un ressenti est-ce
que l'eau dans une bouteille risque de
gelées et bien non elle se refroidira
plus vite que s'il n'y avait pas de vent
mais elle deviendra pas plus froide que
2 degrés la température de l'air enfin
pour finir il ya un autre facteur qui
complique les choses
mais cette fois dans l'autre sens c'est
le soleil les rayons du soleil qui
viennent éventuellement vous frappez
contribuent eux aussi aux flux mais
positivement
ils vous apportent de la chaleur donc il
vaut faire augmenter la température
ressentie le flux que vous recevez du
soleil va dépendre de plusieurs facteurs
sa hauteur dans le ciel qui varie avec
l'heure et la latitude votre orientation
par rapport à lui la couleur de vos
vêtements ou de votre peau etc et
suivant les situations ça peut aller
d'une dizaine de watts à presque 300
watts par mètre carré
voyez donc que même habillé légèrement
dans certains cas le flux positif dû au
soleil peut venir compenser le flux
négatif dû à la température de l'air et
au vent c'est ce qui explique qu'on peut
ne pas avoir froid à la montagne si on
est à midi au soleil
en bref
finir une température ressentie qui est
physiquement et physiologiquement un
sens est complètement impossible
alors plutôt que de vouloir faire du
sensationnalisme il me semble plus
pertinent de donner l'ensemble des
informations météorologiques la
température de l'air l'humidité car elle
joue un rôle aussi un notamment par
forte chaleur la vitesse du vent
l'ensoleillement etc
et laissons les gens s'adapter en
fonction de leurs propres
caractéristiques et leur vécu et on
pourrait simplement accompagné sa d'un
indice d'alert pour prévenir les dangers
de gelures due à la combinaison de
températures très basses et de vents
importants 'l'indice pourrait très bien
être graduée de 0 à 5
sans avoir besoin d'invoquer des
températures ressenties n'ayant aucun
sens
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si ces
notions vous intéresse je donne des
détails sur les principes thermique dans
le billet de blog qui accompagne la
vidéo vous pouvez également aller voir
une vidéo de syllabus qui présente
notamment l'historique des formules un
peu ésotérique qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui
pour calculer certaines de ces
températures ressenties sur la chaîne de
string theory avait également fait un
épisode pour évoquer ces notions et de
façon générale le concept de deux
ponceaux retard mais voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner de mettre la cloche tout ça pour
ne rien rater des publications de la
chaîne facebook et twitter c'est pour
les actus et je vous dis à très bientôt
pour de nouvelles vidéos
[Musique]